major financial institutions have
teetered on the edge of collapse
and some have failed as uncertainty has
grown many banks have restricted lending
credit markets have frozen and families
and businesses have found it harder to
borrow money
we are in the midst of a serious
financial crisis and the federal
government is responding with decisive
action
so i propose that the federal government
reduce the risk posed by these troubled
assets
and supply urgently needed money so
banks and other financial institutions
can avoid collapse
and resume lending this rescue effort is
not aimed at preserving any individual
company or industry
it is aimed at preserving america's
overall economy
in january issue the bailout was far
bigger than the federal reserve let the
public or even members of congress
know at the time during the 2008
meltdown when the government bailed out
too big to fail giants like bear stearns
aig
fannie mae freddie mac who did they hire
to analyze and clean up the mess
another giant financial firm by the name
of blackrock led by a very well
connected billionaire by the name of
larry fink
blackrock was awarded these key
government contracts to help with the
meltdown with no competitive bidding
while being enveloped in secrecy
basically larry fink was hired to be the
manager of washington's bailout of wall
street
even though black rock is one of the
biggest shareholders in the same banks
they were helping to get bailed out
making larry fink the most powerful man
in the post bailout economy
fast forward to the 2020 pandemic rick
quick question for you sir we're just
getting word from the federal reserve
and this might be boosting the markets
even more this afternoon they are
talking about the details
of their corporate bond purchases the
fed making history today and for the
first time ever
began buying corporate debt etfs the
unprecedented move
driving an explosion in the corporate
debt market we are committed to using
our full range of tools to support the
economy and to help assure that the
recovery from this difficult period will
be as robust
as possible but again as i mentioned the
fed two weeks ago began buying
individual corporate bonds and we just
got granular detail about what types of
purchases it made
yesterday and who did the money printer
of the us the federal reserve hired to
manage their scheme to buy corporate
bonds
basically they were bailing out
corporations that had too much debt to
withstand the pandemic
you guessed it they went right back to
blackrock even though again the same
corporations blackrock was helping to
bail out were the same corporations that
they own some of the biggest stakes in
keep in mind though these are just the
top 10 holdings the whole list which the
fed has published on the new york fed
website
includes 794 companies so
yes these are just the top 10 by
holdings but there are hundreds of other
companies
that could be part of the fed's
portfolio as well
larry think was the most powerful man in
the post bailout economy and now he's
arguably one of the most powerful men in
the post-pandemic economy as well
and yet despite all his considerable
power the general public has practically
never heard of larry fink
with blackrock barely coming into the
public eye during the recent claims that
they were buying up single-family homes
that's because larry is smart he's
intentionally kept it that way
he's spent the last 33 years building
blackrock into the biggest asset manager
in the world with over 9 trillion
dollars under their management
not billion trillion with a t today
blackrock's clients include the
retirement
account of average everyday people in
the form of pension funds they also have
sovereign wealth funds as their clients
other central banks college endowments
fortune 500 companies and millions of
individual investors
they're one of the top shareholders of
many of the biggest publicly traded
companies like
apple microsoft facebook and even other
major banks like wells fargo and chase
and to put their 9 trillion dollars into
perspective the 300 largest pension
funds in the world
only hold a collective 6 trillion
dollars vanguard the behemoth behind
mutual funds and etfs trails behind
blackrock were only 7.1 trillion under
management
and if you put the big three asset
management firms together blackrock
vanguard and state street they control a
collective 15 trillion dollars
roughly equivalent to nearly 70 of the
us's gdp
and larry fink has done all of this
largely in the shadows
with just a few occasional interviews
and appearances on cnbc
he's like the wizard of oz the man
behind the curtain as william cohen puts
it
a former investment banker and author of
house of cards an account of the bear
stearns collapse
this is blackrock what some call the
most influential financial institution
in the world
the world's largest shadow bank and
perhaps the company that owns the world
when larry fink was asked by bloomberg
if it's true that he's the most powerful
man in finance
the man responsible for 9 trillion tried
to convince you otherwise
that quote i don't think of myself as
powerful end quote is that true
does blackrock own the world well it's a
little bit complicated
[Music]
larry fink is no doubt an accomplished
man that's pretty bold
yes even a billion dollars can't reverse
a head that's already gone bald
unless you take preventative measures
before the bottling starts happening
did you know two out of every three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern bottling by the time they're 35
not when you're 68 like larry not when
you're 50 not even when you're 40 but 35
and according to my youtube analytics 35
is creeping up real quick for a good
chunk of you and the best way not to go
bald is to do something about it while
you still have hair left that is where
today's video sponsor comes and keeps
keeps is a subscription service that
focuses on making it easier and more
affordable for men to treat their male
pattern baldness online
here's just how easy keeping your hair
can be you choose one of their
affordable plans that best fits your
hair situation
a licensed real doctor will confirm is
everything you need and nothing you
don't all online then you set it and
forget it your keeps treatment is
shipped directly to your door every
three months at half the cost of your
local pharmacy because they use generic
versions of fda approved medications for
hair loss
and then you start using your treatment
you can easily track your progress
online as you keep your hair you have
constant access to your doctor through
online doctor messaging and although
everyone is different people who use
keeps typically start seeing results in
just four to six months so it's super
important for you to act fast the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair you
can save
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.comtrend
or click the link in the description to
get 50
off your first order that's dot com
jake tran or click the link below
[Music]
black rock boast some impressive stats
in 2010 they were called the most
influential financial institution in the
world and in 2014 they had 4 trillion
under management making them the world's
biggest asset manager
for comparison the industrial and
commercial bank of china only had 3
trillion
at that time and as i just mentioned
their assets have doubled to more than
nine trillion dollars over the past
seven years
it seems blackrock has a hand in nearly
everything these days they're a top
shareholder in some of the world's
biggest publicly traded companies
a top shareholder of banks like deutsche
bank at 4.81
in 2020 they were approved by the
chinese government to set up a mutual
fund in china making blackrock the first
foreign asset manager to be greenlighted
for this
they also have shares in companies all
over europe including industries like
energy oil and gas transportation food
and of course finance
and here's the kicker blackrock has
what's called circular ownership
where they own shares in companies that
own shares in blackrock definitely not a
conflict of interest
so they're literally everywhere because
of their staggering size and power and
the fact that they largely operate out
of sight
blackrock has been called the world's
largest shadow bank the question is what
makes someone build something this big
larry fing is known as the guy who
always wanted more than he had
friends have called him obsessive
paranoid about maintaining control
he's been regarded as someone who knows
the marcus inside and out and
understands business backwards and
forwards
but it took him a massive 100 million
loss to get to this point
larry majored in political science at
ucla and got his start on wall street
at age 23. having that edge in politics
would later play a crucial role in him
being the de facto middleman between
washington and wall street
he received offers from some of the top
investment banks but decided on first
boston where he worked on structuring
and trading bonds which sounds
incredibly interesting
he rose up the ranks quickly and within
a decade he became somewhat of a legend
on wall street by helping develop the
debt securitization market
where loans like car loans credit card
loans mortgages would be bundled
together sliced into pieces and sold to
other investors
if this sounds familiar it's because
these are the same mortgage-backed
securities that led to the 2008 meltdown
but before that happened this
securitization of debt was considered
really innovative
and it transformed the face of finance
all of a sudden if you're a giant bank
or pension fund or whatever that wants
to invest in the housing market
you can now invest in a mortgage-backed
security made up of thousands of
hopefully safe loans
very fit created one of the main tools
that led to the meltdown and he was also
the one the us treasury hired to clean
it up
his interest in policy and strategic
wizardry helped him gain a reputation as
a true investment mastermind
and for that he was rewarded larry was
making bank and received a ton of
accolades
at just 31 he became first boston's
youngest managing director in history
many even thought he would go to run the
firm someday in total he helped add
about a billion dollars in assets to
first boston's bottom line
but then the rising star came crashing
down shortly after one of his biggest
wins
larry lost a hundred million dollars for
his company a missed call on his hand
resulted in trades being wiped out as
well as the hedges designed to offset
those losses being wiped out
and overnight larry went from a hero to
a toxic asset that should be avoided at
all times
he was ostracized his reputation went up
in flames and his colleagues wanted
nothing to do with them he was forced
out of the company he spent 12 years
making around a billion dollars for
while a catastrophe like this might mark
the end for many people that wasn't the
case with larry
instead he used it as ammunition vowing
to never find himself in a position
where he didn't understand the risks he
was taking again
and in 1988 he was 35 and hell-bent on
rebooting his career
so larry co-founded the blackstone group
along with now billionaire investor
steven schwartzman
they started off with a 5 million line
of credit fast forward to 1993
and they were crushing it with 20
billion dollars under management but in
what some would call a power struggle
between fink and schwartzman where two
super strong personalities collided
the two parter ways and larry broke off
to found blackrock channeling all his
pain and trauma into growing the firm at
a staggering rate
by 1999 it went public for 375 million
by 2004 it merged with merrill lynch
adding half a trillion dollars to
blackrock's assets
and today it's at 9 trillion while the
size of blackrock is impressive
what really sets them apart is our
software platform called aladdin
basically a super computer they use for
their clients
[Music]
aladdin is a network of 5000 computers
blackrock uses to monitor millions of
trades and analyze their clients
portfolios 24 hours a day to perform
risk analysis aladdin is so widespread
today that it's basically the central
nervous system for many of the largest
players in the investment management
industry
and for them to be able to offer the
service they have to be granted access
to sensitive data from banks insurance
companies pension funds and other
important institutions all over the
world
this high-end computer farm literally
goes over every possible scenario and
pinpoints anything that could possibly
go wrong
allowing their clients to make the best
investment decisions and it's through
aladdin that blackrock actually oversees
more like 21 trillion dollars worth of
assets instead of just 9 trillion
and that's just from a third of
aladdin's 240 clients
which means that one company blackrock
has an eye on the equivalent of at least
10
of all the stocks and bonds in the world
[Music]
2008 the world enters a global financial
crisis that hasn't been seen since the
great depression
and while street needs washington to
bail them out who do they call to manage
the bailout
as you already know blackrock the new
york fed personally went to larry to
help manage 30 billion dollars in toxic
assets from bear stearns
they brought blackrock in to advise them
on how to handle the 100 billion
of toxic assets from aig they even
contracted blackrock to deal with the
301 billion dollars of citigroup's
assets
all of which were done behind closed
doors with no competitive bidding
and just like that larry was more
powerful than ever he went from being
the laughing stock of finance to being
the linchpin between wall street and
washington
as one bank executive said larry has
always wanted to be
important and now he's more important
than he ever dreamed of
and he's loving it in the end they made
at least 200 million
off of these contracts in total the
massive size of these contracts and
secrecy surrounding them
and blackrock's enormous influence
started getting people talking
quote it's like the black water of
finance almost a shadow government
blackwater as in the most infamous
private military contractor during the
war on terror
check out our mini documentary on them
to learn more link below
now on the surface this may sound bad
this may sound pretty shady and corrupt
but if you think about it if the
government is gonna step in which they
are
even though i don't completely agree
with that what else are they gonna do
they're at least partially responsible
for this mess for setting such low
interest rates so they're obviously
already incompetent
they're not experts in things like
mortgage-backed securities so why
wouldn't they go to the man that is an
expert that helped pioneer these things
in the first place
i'm not saying it isn't shady and
corrupt i'm just saying that giving
these million dollar contracts to a man
like larry fink is
understandable
[Music]
and it didn't stop there when do you
know what hit the fan in march 2020 with
kovan blackrock came to the rescue for
both wall street and the government
again
the federal reserve hired them to help
bailout corporations with too much debt
or they needed to borrow money to stay
afloat which again included corporations
they have huge stakes in which is again
definitely not a conflict of interest
they also helped the fed purchase more
mortgage-backed securities on top of
that
so where does blackrock go moving
forward what does a man do when he
already has everything
in 2019 people were petitioning against
blackrock for being among the top
shareholders for oil and co-production
in fact investing in heavy pollution
industries has basically been the
backbone of blackrock's portfolio
over the years so according to larry
they're making a push towards
environmental social and sustainable
investing
whether or not they actually believe in
this stuff is yet to be known
nevertheless it does appear they've made
legit efforts to expand into this more
eco-friendly markets with new
environmentally focused
products they've partnered with activist
investors they backed a shareholder
resolution basically forcing exxon mobil
to get serious about climate change
larry even straight up wrote a letter
telling companies that they need to
quote
contribute to society to receive his
firm's support this new push for
sustainable investing or esg investing
is a big reason why you see so many
corporations trying to appear woke these
days
if you want to invest in a company they
will on their investor relations page
they'll show you their esg
score esg stands for environmental
social
corporate governance and this is where
the woke culture comes from so
they've created this kind of phony
baloney rating system that says well if
you i'm
i'm exaggerating but if you mentioned
that you are you know
have a green agenda and you and you
believe in carbon credits and you might
trade some credit somewhere then you get
a higher score and therefore you're more
investable
and it's very interesting to see how big
investors like insurance companies
institutional investors
they are steering away from anything
that does not have the right esg
rating and so in order to have investors
continue to be interested in the stock
which is important for the company for
its perception certainly for the
uh the officers of the company and the
shareholders
you have to move this move this along
continuously and so it's very simple to
see why doing a woke ad
as nike or as any other company and
pride month is fantastic because you
could and pride is easy throw up some
flags show the right people
trends whatever right and you got a high
esg score
[Music]
the main catalyst for larry success is
the sole crushing humiliation he
experienced after losing a hundred
million dollars that's what really
catapulted blackrock into what it is
today
he put his entire being into the company
and most people agree that he's still as
driven as ever today
when asked on a personal level what's
important this is what he had to say
this may sound trade but it's really
important for me to be perceived as a
good human being a caring individual
that always comes across as real and
unpretentious and one thing i tell
everybody you may not be able to print
this is that i'm the same turd i was 30
years ago
and i'm really proud of that
[Music]
if there is indeed an american oligarchy
today larry fink would definitely be one
of them
but is he a good oligarch or a bad one
are they just putting on a show to keep
the public at bay
how influential is blackrock really how
much control over the world do they
really have
let me know what you think in the
comments below
so what is your verdict on blackrock do
they own the world
how much influence do they really have
one interesting thing that i found was
that larry fink is only worth around a
billion dollars even though his company
manages over 9 trillion at least
according to forrest unless it's more
unreported
so let me know what you guys think as
always in the comments below and yes
i'm well aware that the purple in my
hair or however it shows up on camera
makes me look
like an sjw but as always it will fade
out to a more natural looking blonde
so don't worry i'm not going full sjw
speaking of hair you should check out
keeps our videos sponsored with the link
below
men don't really have many ways to
express themselves visually there's not
really much men's fashion like at all
compared to women's fashion and it's
something that you can probably
tell the eye value so i really value
hair and what it can do
to your style and your look so that is
why i am supporting keeps so you should
do what you can to protect it before too
much falls out
pieces will be linked below check them
out support the channel and if you are
new here we make video essays just like
this
on the most provocative
thought-provoking stuff in the world of
business just like this video
and many others that we have on this
channel for free so click the subscribe
button below
and remember you can always dislike and
unsubscribe and leave me your best hate
comments
in the comments below so you have
nothing to lose instagram if you want
behind the scenes stuff in the live kind
of stuff
that kind of thing you can follow me on
instagram at jtrend.io we have a lot of
fun over there and that is going to wrap
up this video thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome i've been
jake stay dangerous out there
and i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you